what'd you guys do this weekend anything
that played hockey oh yeah how'd that go
Gary Gary you don't play hockey do you
no have you ever played before this was
the yesterday was the third time I'd
ever been I played ice hockey the second
time was the night before and the first
time was the day before Christmas you
got to play at Madison Square Garden
which is a rare dream for anybody dream
of doing that who's on your team Rick
Moranis yeah who's a really really nice
guy and a big fan of the show he's a
great uh performer a couple of X Rangers
I know on my team was this guy Chris
Jericho he's a WWF wrestler and then you
know Messier was there later on and all
those guys because they were doing some
sort of skills competition right Dennis
Leary was on the other team and Jason
Priestley was on the other team because
it was for the Christopher Reef
Foundation right so the media was
Christopher Reeve there he was here's
something really stupid that I did this
incredibly hot woman comes out to sing
the national anthem they introduced this
woman and she's really gorgeous and she
comes out and she does an incredible job
who is it so afterwards I see her
hanging around Christopher Reeve and I
thought oh there's some woman that's
part of the foundation and she comes up
to me and she thanks me for all all that
we've done on the show for promoting
thank you so much for doing this oh no
problem
[Music]
so much you did a great job she said we
are huge fans and I said well you know
what do you do with the foundation she
goes I'm Christopher Marie's wife what
do you do with the foundation what do I
do I'm married to the I'm married Chris
I had no idea I'm sorry I had no idea
well we promote we promoted it for like
a couple weeks though that's great oh
thank you it's very nice to meet you
too and thanks again for coming and
please give our best we'll be out again
next year Chris Reeve watches the show
Superman yes they love the show so what
happened when you went out there you
probably get your ass kicked that wasn't
awful but I was pretty bad oh man let me
see
Here Comes Gary
[Laughter]
oh that's hard I would I've never even
ice skated I wouldn't even know how to
do it and then play a game yeah and then
hold a stick and do stuff but but here's
a weird thing I think I scored a goal
did you play
[Applause]
listen to what I did at practice uh Ron
duguay who's married to Kim Alexis was
there and they're there with their three
kids in 20 minutes I knocked down the 10
year old you're right sorry man knock
down Kim Alexis
sorry I'm I'm really bad and had the
puck stolen away by the five-year-old
really yeah but you know what happened
you know I I knocked down Kim Alexis and
she looked how'd you do that you know we
were like sort of butt to butt I didn't
see her and like I hit her and she went
down and she got up and she gave me this
look like what the f is wrong with you
right no can't you skate yeah and I went
up there and I said listen you know I'm
really not that good I wasn't doing
anything stupid or anything right
because then people start to wonder
whether we're just being idiot right
right right uh well Gary congratulations
on your celebrity hockey thank you
foreign